[Music]
the rail strikes have brought huge parts
of britain to a standstill recently but
this could be just the beginning
i think there are going to be many
unions balloting across the country
because people can't take it anymore
britain's biggest trade unions are
mobilizing arguing that pay and
conditions for millions of workers are
lagging behind the soaring cost of
living
it could mean a wave of strikes not seen
since the 1970s when millions of workers
walked out
this is the story of three public sector
workers and their case for better pay
more and more people are saying actually
enough enough we've got no money when it
gets to a point where you can't cover
the bills and you're not even keeping up
anywhere near with inflation i feel like
something has to be done
i love my job i can't give it up not yet
that's why i'm fighting now
[Music]
in the late 1970s inflation was soaring
just as it is today britain was on the
cusp of a pivotal event that would see
the government and the powerful trade
unions going head-to-head
the pickets way through only ici's own
fleet of lorries all other vehicles are
stopped we've had no overall since
christmas before christmas
thousands of workers on t side will be
joining the many who've already been
laid off
back then the unions demanded greater
pay rises for their members but the
labor government refused
and over a long and bitterly cold winter
strikes broke out train drivers nurses
lorry drivers even the gravediggers
walked out
and towards the end of 1978 the bin men
went on strike and the rubbish piled
high
this the now famous winter of discontent
[Applause]
as we said
we're fighting anywhere
today those very same conditions exist
that could see another wave of
industrial action
so one of the things i've been doing
recently is making like milkshakes and
meal replacement things
instead of eating at work because it
works out a lot cheaper
katie sutton is a nurse in the nhs this
is basically just a calorie shake
probably a meal yeah i will make up one
of these shake it up leave it in the
fridge and
for less than two pounds i've got 400
calories and it will keep me going
katie this is
to a lot of people this might seem quite
bizarre because it's just a shake and
that's what you're doing to save money
is it yeah
this is cheaper than cooking one meal
by right away
katie earns 35
629 pounds a year maybe it's payday
tomorrow i've lost track um and i'm
about 150 200 pounds in my over after
the moment
which fortunately i get 250 pound
without having to pay interest but
it sounds desperate
yeah
well
and you would say the the big
a big proportion of this is not only
that things are rising fuel and fuel but
fundamentally you would say you are not
earning enough yeah exactly yeah
while average wages have increased many
public sector workers are worse off than
they were a decade ago because pay
hasn't increased as much as prices have
real pay taking inflation into account
is actually 3.1 percent lower than in
2012 for primary school teachers and 1.9
percent lower for secondary school
teachers nurses and firefighters look to
be marginally better off than they were
a decade ago but that's not the full
story the rise and the cost of living
means that public sector pay in real
terms is actually four percent lower
than last year
[Music]
so we um we had a cell fire at the local
prison um which we turned out to which
was out on arrival that's probably a job
mate sorry
on the day we met adam hooks he's
already tackled a fire at a prison and
when he got back he was immediately
called out again
[Applause]
now he's being tasked with removing a
ring from a swollen finger caused by an
insect bite don't worry about it i've
only chopped three fingers off so far
as an experienced firefighter adam earns
a basic salary of 32
244 pounds a year there you go there's
your ring okay can you take that back
bless you
so i've been a whole term firefighter
for just over four years
so what's changed for you in the last
few months then it's difficult pretty
much like you you're kind of having an
overlook on everything now it's you're
kind of going back to basics and
thinking do i need this anymore so when
it gets to a point where you can't cover
the bills because
you're not hit inflation's that high and
you're not even keeping up anywhere near
with inflation
i feel like something has to be done
i'd like to have enough money to not
have to worry about things
the government says a hike in public
sector pay would cause a spike in demand
for goods and services and that would
cause prices to rise even more we can't
fix the increase in the cost of living
just by increasing wages to match the
surge in prices
but the cost of living isn't slowing
down either new forecasts suggest energy
bills could rise to more than 4
200 pounds in april wiping out the 15
billion pound support package the
government has pledged to help
struggling families
where are my school shoes well you need
your trainers don't you the other thing
is my school shoes are your trainers
i've come to meet rachel badzier a
special needs teacher and her two
children violet age 13 and billy age 10.
how difficult is it to try to keep
trying to find those savings and trying
to balance the defense well it is i just
have to make sure that i don't overspend
but you notice that where i could spend
30 40 quid i'm now spending 60 pounds
because and i don't really think that
i've bought anything different
rachel says her salary of 35 000 pounds
a year isn't going up enough to match
the rising cost of living
pay rises for public sector workers like
nurses and teachers are determined by
independent pay review bodies
the pay body sh will be looking at
nurses railway workers
and teachers and there will have to be
there will have to be priorities made so
i mean i mean and i can understand it's
not fine we don't there's no finite
purse that i mean there never has been
and so it is that thing of where you've
got to think
is it how can you prioritize yes you
might be a nurse and you save lives in
that way however in the flip side of
that the reason that you are a nurse is
because you have teachers to help you
get through your life to get to where
you are
more and more people are saying actually
enough is enough we've got no money it's
coming to be like a big 70s britain
by the late 1970s britain led by
labour's james callahan was in serious
financial trouble
and i emphasize to you that if we fail
to bring down inflation we shall never
succeed in overcoming unemployment
millions of working days were being lost
to the strikes and in the end workers
secured the wage rise as they were
fighting for
but it left labor damaged
and they lost the next election
katie has been offered a 4 pay rise this
year do you see strikes coming down the
line in the nursing profession yes
absolutely i want to say that we just
walk out and you but then you know who
does look after the patients appears to
me that you're not ready to strike
at the moment i'm not but that's at the
moment and if this continues then i will
take some kind of industrial action but
i prefer it not to be needed i prefer
the government just listen to us do you
think they will
i don't know
i don't think so
ready one two three go go go
firefighters like adam have been offered
a 2 pay rise this year the fire brigades
union called that offer utterly
inadequate good vlad high five high five
good man
if the offer is not increased in the
autumn firefighters will be asked to
vote on a strike
if it came to it would you strike
it's a it's a very difficult question
because
no no firefighter wants to strike a lot
of us live in that community so it has
also an effect on ourselves as well not
just everyone else and and we do the job
because we want to help people we do
need to listen to it and there is a lot
of firefighters that are struggling with
the wages and just trying to pay the
bills never mind having any sort of
luxuries in with anything
today we're going to learn all about
careers
rachel's part of the national education
union this autumn members will be asked
if they're prepared to strike
the union is calling it the biggest
ballot of teachers in a generation
are you worried that the public
parents in particular i think
might not have as much sympathy with
teachers who want to strike as perhaps
you would like definitely i can i can
definitely understand that because being
a parent myself you know the impact that
teachers not being in school has on your
own children and you know the disruption
that it can cause and i do think that
that adds an extra weight to my decision
making
so you're not decided i'm not fully
decided
that's my dad
he was in the territorial army so i've
got his uh medals as well
for the first time since she qualified
as a nurse katie is considering her
future
how would it feel
if it came to the
crunch and you had to give it up
i don't want to think about that
i remember the look on my dad's face
before he passed away
and i told him that i'd finally got the
job and
he said good on you kid
i love my job
i worked so hard for it and i made my
dad so proud by getting it
i don't want to give this up
i can't give it up not yet
that's why i'm fighting now
well it's right that we reward our
hard-working public sector workers with
a pay rise but that needs to be
proportionate and balanced with the need
not to make the inflationary pressures
worse and also to see what's affordable
for the taxpayer i'm on the side of
people who work hard who go into work
who want to run their businesses we
can't see them hampered by the
activities of these militant unions
the next few weeks and months could see
millions of workers balloted for strike
action
a new wave of discontent
in an age-old struggle